everyone sorry Jesus birthday is May  because there's special TV shows come on  what's the difference between because  I'm Hanukkah Santa doesn't call and on  Christmas Santa does and they built him  it's only celebrate you start this by  saying my favorite thing is opening the  presents because usually I get two big  stars like with any love I know maybe  iPad cuz I got an iPad last year for  Christmas for my uncle what do you want  for Hanukkah this year I ang to me  that's calm I'm not gonna play so loud  in there but uh I think presents people  make our badges and presents the people  by because it makes more love like it  gives me like you're giving more loved  it's homemade it's like more love what  do you like better giving people  presents or getting presents  I'm Kevin I'm soon I'm gonna marry my  patron Evan past I wasn't